at weapons and bombs every 24 died
we call upon revolutionary movements
everywhere to focus the attention of the
world on the Palestinian people's
struggle
welcome to Entebbe Uganda there are 239
hostages at Entebbe 83 are Israeli the
Germans separated the juice we have to
act
there could be no negotiations with
terrorists you want to invent Uganda she
would we give it back to them when we
leave this man bear no grudge against
you but if your government do not Lukas
it they will kill to children every 24
hours to resist me will be shot if you
want to take control of the airport I'm
gonna have to use a much bigger force
but it's impossible to move a force of
that size 4000 kilometers are detected
we capture Syria do nothing why are you
here want to throw bombs into the
consciousness of the masses and what if
you have to throw your own my friend are
you ready to kill are you ready to die
all the officials in Uganda use a black
limousine that gives us the element of
surprise if the mission fails to blow to
Israel will be catastrophic we stop for
nothing until all the hostages are safe
here we go
they have TNT on the plane and all
around the building
as soon as they know we're coming they
start to kill the man the women the
children they want the world to watch
whatever happens we did the right thing
you
you